here's an excellent question we have the  sum of three numbers where each number  is a nested exponent the first number  read from left to right is three three  eight zero five six the second number is  two four one two zero six five and the  third number is six two zero one two  three  to solve this problem we'll use exponent  rules if you have nested exponents you  want to group and work from the top down  then zero raised to any positive power  is equal to zero so we can simplify all  three numbers in this way  then any non-zero number raised to the  power of zero is equal to one so we  simplify the first and third numbers in  this way  one raised to any power is equal to one  so we'll simplify the second number  finally x to the power of one is equal  to X so we can simplify all three  numbers  we are left with three to the power 3  which is 27 2 to the power of four which  is sixteen and six is six add these  together and we get the answer of 49.